[Applause]
isaiah
there's just something so fresh and
beautiful and romantic about your
approach
what gave you the idea to do it the way
you do it
uh i mean i think it's beautiful to see
things through a point of view first of
all and obviously i told you last time
the pandemic was
a tough time for a lot of people so you
know you just want to see goodness you
want to see kindness during that time
and inspire a lot of people so i thought
you know i might be the beacon to do it
and you inspire me a lot too so i'm so
relieved because you really are my
example and i just think you do it in
your own isaiah way thank you and i mean
how many followers do you have on tick
tock now like seven million i mean it's
insane i have two million like do you
know what i mean
but you're a legend you have no idea
it makes me so happy that people are in
the right place sure when they're with
you it's like i want when people follow
someone to be that example we all want
to have fun and entertain and escape and
but to be inspired the way that you are
inspiring people is so amazing so
you brought uh something here today and
so i'm in your passenger seat you're the
driver take it away isaiah okay guys so
i have this brown paper bag here and it
says judy murphy is the ceo of kindness
so judy murphy is
a bagel shop owner who is doing some
incredible things for the community um
just amazing human being guys
and
one thing that we thought was really
really cool is judy actually puts up
these brown paper bags inside of her
bagel shop and she puts really cool
notes on them like ten dollars for
whatever you want in the store or free
coffee or free bagel and people who are
going through really really hard times
could just walk up and literally
literally like redeem one for themselves
when they're going through hard times so
she's an amazing human being
she's such a perfect person
that's the other thing that you do
isaiah is we love you and the way you do
it but you bring these people into our
world
and someone like judy and her approach
you bring it to the forefront you're
telling her story
and um judy is actually in our audience
today
so
judy
uh i was wondering if you don't mind
coming up actually
onto the stage
i hope we're not catching you too off
guard we love surprises around here
um how did you find your style because
this is what i made for you and
to put your unique stamp
what was it about the paper bag that
gave you the idea how did you make this
such an artistic
giving judy stamped approach to all of
this what was the inspiration
there were so many people in need in our
community and we just thought it was a
simple way we just one of my me and one
of my employees came up with it we just
started writing on bags and hanging them
on the wall behind us
and customers would come in and ask
about it and they'd either take a bag
off the wall or they were paying it
forward and they were buying bags and
putting them on the wall
how do you feel like your community made
all this possible ah they're amazing
people
one gentleman came in and he paid for
his eighteen dollar bill with a hundred
dollar bill and he said keep the change
and put bags on the wall
so that's what it's all and every and
every day people are putting bags on the
wall and every day people are coming in
unfortunately and taking bags off the
wall
so
not only did you kind of come up with
this poetic beautiful philanthropic
community
building idea but now people are
inspired to build on it they bring their
own bags they just say they want to put
a bag on the wall and they we just write
up the bag or sometimes they'll write up
the bag and decorate it and stick it up
on the wall okay we have in the store
okay and you have said that like you
never know what tomorrow can bring
um and so i was interested in what
exactly that meant for you
my dad died when i was 14. i was the
youngest of four and he suddenly died he
he was a police officer and healthy and
he passed away about a week after he had
gotten sick
and my mother just pulled up the
bootstraps and did what she had to do
and and you just don't know i mean any
one of us could be in a situation where
we need a bag off the wall one day
so
thank you judy for sharing that with us
really and truly
not that it takes away the pain you
didn't deserve to have
but i'm glad that your mother
could live on to inspire you so that you
could start a movement yourself yeah my
mom was amazing
she really was i just want you to look
into our audience right now because
guess what everyone has a paper bag
with a message
written
to you about how you've inspired us
today
and that is what i'm talking about about
the poetry you've taken this you know
utilitarian
beautiful
piece of paper
it's like you've turned it back into the
tree it once was and now it grows into
something so beautiful in honor of the
seed you planted
thank you thank you so much thank you
thank you for telling your story today
and we also know that you need to keep
going and keeping this movement alive
and the embers and the flames burning so
our friends at restaurant depot have a
five thousand dollar gift card for you
in your bag
for the new york bagel company
so you can just continue your mission
of feeding those in need
and keeping a behavior and an artistic
approach to taking care of one another
thank you so much
and you know isaiah once again thank you
for always telling us these stories
[Music]